In beer and wine production, enzymes in yeast
aid the conversion of sugar into ethanol.
Enzymes are used in cheese-making to degrade
proteins in milk, changing their solubility,
and causing the proteins to precipitate. Many
industrial processes ranging from fruit juice
production to paper production to biofuel
production utilize enzymes. In this video
you'll see that studying how enzymes catalyze
reactions can help us design better therapeutics.
This video is part of the Differential Equations
video series. Laws that govern a system's
properties can be modeled using differential
equations.
Hi. My name is Krystyn Van Vliet and I am
a professor in the Materials Science and Engineering
and Biological Engineering departments at
MIT.
of reactions and after some practice, you
will be able to derive a rate law for a general
enzyme-catalyzed reaction.
In order to understand the topic of this video,
you should be familiar with determining rate
laws from experimental data, predicting rate
laws from proposed chemical reaction mechanisms,
and have some basic understanding of the effects
of catalysts on the kinetics of a reaction.
The
study of enzyme catalysis has become important
for drug development. Many drugs work by inhibiting
an enzyme.
For example, enzymes thought to be important
for the survival and replication of the parasite
that causes malaria are being explored as
therapeutic targets. The parasites enter the
red blood cells of the host and use proteases
to catalyze the degradation of the hemoglobin
inside of the red blood cells. Degrading hemoglobin,
a protein, yields amino acids, which can then
be used by the parasite for its own protein
synthesis. Protease inhibitors could help
slow the degradation of hemoglobin, which
in turn would slow the growth and reproduction
of the malaria parasite.
When a potential inhibitor is identified,
kinetic data is used to evaluate its efficacy.
In order to understand how this can be done,
let's start by describing the kinetics of
a simpler case -- that of an enzyme catalyzed
reaction without an inhibitor present. Then
we'll think about what might happen if we
throw an inhibitor into the mix.
This video will help you describe enzyme catalysis
mathematically by first reviewing some common
biochemical terms, then by describing the
general characteristics of enzyme-catalyzed
you will encounter throughout your undergraduate
experience.
a reactant is called a substrate. This is
really just a matter of different fields using
different terms, but it's important for you
to be aware of this. Next, catalysts found
in biological organisms are called enzymes.
Textbooks frequently abbreviate "substrate"
using the letter "S" and enzyme using the
letter "E."
How do enzymes work? If we look at a reaction
coordinate, recall that the transition state
represents a chemical species intermediate
between the reactant, or substrate in this
case, and the product. The potential energy
difference between the transition state and
the reactants is the activation energy for
the forward reaction. The potential energy
difference between the transition state and
the products is the activation energy for
the reverse reaction. Only reactants with
the energy to overcome the activation energy
will form products.
Like synthetic catalysts, enzymes accelerate
the rates of reactions by stabilizing the
transition state, lowering its potential energy,
and providing a new pathway by which the reaction
can occur. This new reaction pathway has a
lower activation energy than the uncatalyzed
path making it more likely that a greater
number of reactant molecules will have the
energy needed to overcome the activation energy
and proceed to product.
Enzymes facilitate reactions, but, like other
catalysts, are not consumed in the reaction.
Enzymes are typically proteins, but RNA has
also been shown to catalyze reactions.
While there are different theories about how
enzymes work to catalyze reactions, there
are a couple of things that are agreed upon.
One is that enzymes have a region called an
active site. Substrates bind to this region.
The shape and chemistry of the active site
determine the selectivity of the enzyme for
particular substrates.
The second point is that when a substrate
binds to an enzyme, an enzyme-substrate complex
is formed. This enzyme-substrate complex is
a reaction intermediate, meaning that it is
formed and consumed in the reactions, but
does not appear in the overall chemical equation.
For many enzyme-catalyzed reactions, if we
were to measure the rate of reaction at various
substrate concentrations, we would see that
the rate of reaction appears to follow first
order kinetics at low substrate concentrations
and then transitions to behavior that resembles
zero-order kinetics at high substrate concentrations.
Please pause the video here, turn to the person
beside you and discuss what it means for a
reaction to be first-order or zero-order.
Remember, in a first-order reaction, the reaction
rate is directly proportional to the concentration
of substrate. In a zero-order reaction, the
reaction rate is constant as the reaction
progresses and is unaffected by substrate
concentration. So, if we look at this data,
we see that, for a given enzyme concentration,
the addition of substrate above a certain
value has no effect on the rate of reaction.
So let's think about what reaction mechanism
might explain this data.
Some scientists hypothesized that after an
enzyme and substrate combine to form the enzyme-substrate
complex, this complex yields the product and
degrades to regenerate free enzyme. Does the
rate law derived from this reaction mechanism
fit the experimental data?
Let's derive the rate law and see. We can
derive this rate law just as we would for
other chemical systems.
Remember, each step of a reaction mechanism
is assumed to be an elementary reaction. Please
pause the video here, turn to the person beside
you and discuss how you determine the rate
law for an elementary reaction.
Remember, for an elementary reaction, you
CAN predict the rate law from the chemical
equation.
With this in mind, can you write a differential
equation for the rate of product formation
with time? Please pause the video, try to
write the equation, and continue playing the
video to see if you are correct.
From the 2nd step of the reaction mechanism,
we can write that the rate of formation of
product is equal to the rate constant k2 multiplied
by the concentration of our enzyme-substrate
complex.
The enzyme-substrate complex is a reaction
intermediate and not something that is easily
measured in experiments. How can we verify
if this expression is correct? It would be
nice to restate the rate in terms of quantities
that are more easily measured such as the
substrate concentration and the initial enzyme
concentration.
To get an expression for the concentration
of the enzyme-substrate complex, let's write
a differential equation for the net rate of
change of the enzyme-substrate complex concentration
with time. Please pause the video here, try
to write the differential equation, and then
continue playing the video to see if you are
correct.
If we want to write an expression for d[ES]/dt,
we see that in the first step of our mechanism,
the enzyme-substrate complex is produced in
the forward direction and consumed in the
reverse direction. In the second step, the
enzyme-substrate complex is converted into
product.
This equation introduces two additional unknowns:
the free enzyme concentration and substrate
concentration. So, we need two additional
equations in order to solve it.
Can you write an equation for the rate of
change of substrate concentration with time?
Please pause the video here, try to write
the differential equation, and then continue
playing the video to see if you are correct.
If we want to write an expression for d[S]/dt,
we see that the substrate will be consumed
in the forward direction and produced in the
reverse direction of the first step of the
reaction mechanism.
We still need one more equation. This equation
is a simple relationship that says we know
how much enzyme we added to our reaction mixture
at time zero, so at any time, we know that
the amount of free enzyme plus the amount
of enzyme bound in the enzyme-substrate complex
should equal the initial amount added. This
could also be written in differential form
as d[E]/dt plus d[ES]/dt is equal to zero.
So, we have a system of four ordinary differential
equations with four variables that all depend
on time. Equation 1 and Equation 4 have analytic
solutions, but Equations 2 and 3 contain a
non-linear term. When you learn about differential
equations in your future courses, you'll see
why these equations are difficult to solve
and that you will need numerical methods to
solve them.
Here, we have integrated these equations numerically
using the boundary conditions that at time
equals zero, the substrate concentration is
S0, the product concentration is zero, the
enzyme concentration is E0 and the concentration
of enzyme bound to substrate is zero.
We see that after a short start-up period,
the concentration of enzyme bound to substrate
remains approximately constant. In this region,
where the substrate concentration is much
greater than E0, as enzyme is released from
the enzyme-substrate complex, it quickly recombines
with available substrate.
As more substrate is converted to product
and the substrate concentration approaches
E0, the concentration of enzyme bound to substrate
is no longer constant.
In the regime where the substrate concentration
IS greater than E0, we can make a steady-state
approximation and set d[ES]/dt equal to zero.
This approximation will allow us to obtain
an analytic expression for the concentration
of enzyme bound to substrate.
Setting d[ES]/dt equal to zero allows us to
solve for the concentration of enzyme-substrate
complex, which is equal to the rate constant
k1 times the concentration of free enzyme
times the concentration of substrate divided
by the sum of k-1 and k2.
Let's lump the rate constants into a new term
called Km and substitute this into our expression
for the concentration of enzyme-substrate
complex.
Now we can use this expression... ... to rewrite
d[P]/dt.
Let's try to eliminate the concentration of
free enzyme from this expression. We can use
the enzyme balance that we wrote earlier,
which said that the concentration of free
enzyme plus the concentration of enzyme-substrate
complex should equal the initial enzyme concentration.
Substituting our expression for the concentration
of ES into the enzyme balance and doing a
little bit of algebra, we can solve for the
concentration of free enzyme.
And finally, we can substitute this into our
equation for d[P]/dt and obtain this expression.
Let's check this rate law against our experimental
data. At low substrate concentration, the
expression reduces to a first-order rate law
and at high substrate concentration; the expression
reduces to a zero order rate law.
It turns out that the rate law that we just
derived is called the Michaelis-Menten equation.
To make our equation look more like the version
of the Michaelis-Menten equation that you
will see in textbooks, there are a couple
of terms that we will use because they are
the convention in enzyme kinetics. Instead
of saying d[P]/dt is the rate of the reaction,
we will call it the velocity of the reaction
and use the notation of 'v.'
Finally, we'll lump k2[E]o into a term called
vmax. At high substrate concentration, the
reaction velocity approaches vmax.
Remember that lump parameter Km? We can determine
Km from experimental data. If we look at the
substrate concentration needed to reach half
of vmax, we see that the concentration of
substrate required equals Km. Km values for
many enzyme-substrate pairs can be found in
the literature allowing for comparison.
You may be wondering why we went through all
of this. Let's go back to our drug development
example.
Let's say that you have designed a drug that
you think will inhibit one of the proteases
used by the malaria parasite to degrade hemoglobin.
How will you test its effectiveness?
First, you might add a fixed amount of protease
to solutions of varying hemoglobin concentration
in order to measure reaction rates. Let's
say that this reaction follows Michaelis-Menten
kinetics well and that you are able to estimate
vmax and Km.
Next, you repeat the experiment, but this
time, you also add a fixed amount of the drug
candidate to all of your solutions. You get
your rate data and see that the apparent vmax
has decreased. But what does this mean? Can
you speculate how this inhibitor works?
Is the drug interacting with the enzyme and
preventing it from binding substrate?
Is the drug interacting with the enzyme-substrate
complex? Is it something else entirely?
The thought process that you used today to
derive the Michaelis-Menten equation can be
used to derive rate laws for other reaction
mechanisms. Then you can see which mechanism
is best supported by the data.
Today we learned a little bit about the importance
of enzymes and derived a rate law from a general
reaction mechanism using differential equations
and a steady-state approximation. This rate
law was compared against experimental rate
data for an enzyme catalyzing the conversion
of a substrate to a product. The equation
that we derived is called the Michaelis-Menten
equation. While all enzyme-catalyzed reactions
may not exhibit Michaelis-Menten kinetics,
the same logic that you used to derive the
equation can be used to derive rate laws for
other proposed reaction mechanisms.